and unsurprising perhaps that Grant
chaps is the name of the frame because
he caused Havoc if you remember about
three weeks ago Sky News reported that
when Liz trust sacked Grant chat as the
transport secretary from Boris Johnson's
government she said the following to him
she said you're the best Minister for
the job in the cabinet I think you're
the best Communicator in the cabinet but
you're not part of my team there's no
room at the Inn Now Grant chaps did not
take that lying down and help coordinate
throughout conference uh the Rebellion
alongside Michael Gove that effectively
killed the 45p top-rate attack that
effectively uh ended uh that was the
first stage the beginning of the end for
that mini budget uh that quasi quateng
had announced just days before and has
been an absolute thought in the side
he's known as a numbers man when it
comes to the to Parliament he was
thought to be active in organizing the
Rebellion against Liz Truss so that
would be a very good reason for this
trust to bring Grant chaps back into the
fold to stop him plotting to keep him on
side to remove that thorn in the side of
her government it would be a dramatic
appointment because it's clearly
somebody who has criticized an awful lot
of what she has done but I I understand
uh that Liz that Grant chaps is the
primary name in the frame for Liz truss
when looking to replace uh sowella
Braverman but politics a magical thing
at the moment uh people don't always
necessarily do what they're told so
we're going to again have to wait for
the official confirmation uh but uh from
inside the top of government I am being
told that it is likely to be Grant chaps
that's who they want uh uh in the job
and that's the direction uh that things
are going at the moment partly to
quarterize some of the wounds uh that
Grant chat has caused uh in the way that
uh in the way that he has rebelled
against Liz trust in her short
Premiership uh and sought to kind of
call some difficulties but of course you
are swapping one Rebel from outside
outside government in you're also
creating another Rebel uh with the exit
of sowella brevlin over that security
issue that Sky News revealed not that
long ago so perhaps Nick this doesn't
make uh Liz drost's job any easier or
any more difficult because there are the
same number of opponents Rebels people
who might cause a fuss on the back
benches uh that there were a couple of
hours ago but needs must for Liz truss
at the moment things are very tricky so
you can see why she would want to go for
Grant chat if he agrees but that's the
intention inside number 10 at the moment